Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
You will not believe the things you will see
in this episode, I promise.
Earlier we saw that OpenAI’s GPT3 and Codex
AI techniques can be used to solve grade school
level math brain teasers, then, they were
improved to be able to solve university-level
math questions.
Note that this technique required additional
help to do that.
And, a followup work could even take a crack
at roughly a third of mathematical olympiad
level math problems.
And now, let’s see what the excellent scientists
at DeepMind have been up to in the meantime.
Check this out - this is AlphaCode.
What is that?
Well, in college, computer scientists learn
how to teach the computers to program themselves.
Now, DeepMind decided to instead, teach them
how to program themselves.
Wow.
Now, here you see an absolute miracle in the
making.
Look.
Here is the description of the problem, and
here is the solution.
Well, I hear you saying, Károly, there is
no solution here.
And you are indeed right, just give it a second.
Yes, that’s right!
Now, hold on to your papers, and marvel at
how this AI is coding up the solution right
on front of our eyes!
But that’s nothing, we can also ask what
the neural network is looking at.
Check this out!
It is peeping at different, important parts
of the problem statement, and proceeds to
write the solution taking these into consideration.
You see that it also looks at different parts
of the previous code that it had written to
make sure that the new additions are consistent
with those.
Wow.
That is absolutely amazing.
It almost feels like watching a human solve
this problem.
Well, it solved this problem correctly.
Unbelievable.
So, how good is it?
Well, it can solve solve about 34% of the
problems in this dataset.
What does that mean?
Is that good or bad?
Now, if you have been holding on to your papers
so far, now, squeeze that paper, because it
means that it roughly matches the expertise
level of the average human competitor.
Let’s stop there for a moment and think
about that.
An AI that understands of an English description
mixed in with mathematical notation, and codes
up a solution as well as the average human
competitor, at least, on the tasks given in
this dataset.
So, what is this wizardry, and what is the
key?
Well, let’s pop the hood, and have a look
together!
Oh yes!
One of the keys here is that it generates
a ton of candidate programs and is able to
filter them down to just a few promising solutions.
And, it can do this quickly and accurately.
This is huge.
Why?
Because this means that the AI is able to
have a quick look at a computer program and
tell with a pretty high accuracy whether this
will solve the given task or not.
It has an intuition of sorts, if you will.
Now, interestingly, it also uses 41 billion
parameters. 41 billion is tiny compared to
OpenAI’s GPT-3, which has 175 billion.
This means that currently, AlphaCode uses
a more compact neural network, and it is possible
that the number of parameters can be increased
here to further improve the results.
If we look at DeepMind’s track record of
improving on these ideas, I have no doubt
that however amazing these results seem now,
we have really seen nothing yet.
And wait, there is more - this is where I
completely lost my papers: in the case that
you see here, it even learned to invent algorithms.
A simple one, mind you, this is DFS, a search
algorithm that is taught in first-year undergrad
computer science courses, but that does not
matter.
What matters is that this is an AI that can
finally, invent new things.
Wow.
A Google engineer, who is also a world-class
competitive programmer was also asked to have
a look at these solutions, and he was quite
happy with the results.
He said to one of the solutions that “it
looks like it could easily be written by a
human, very impressive!”
Now, clearly, it is not perfect, and thus,
some criticisms were also voiced.
For instance, sometimes it forgets about variables
that remain unused.
Even that is very humanlike, I must say.
But, do not think of this paper as the end
of something.
This is but a stepping stone towards something
much greater.
And I will be honest - I can’t even imagine
what we will have just a couple more papers
down the line.
What a time to be alive!
So, what would you use this for?
What do you think will happen a couple papers
down the line?
I’d love to know - let me know in the comments
below.
And, if you are also excited to hear about
potential followup papers to this, make sure
to subscribe and hit the bell icon.
You definitely not want to not miss it when
it comes!
Thanks for watching and for
your generous support, and I'll see you
next time!